could I speak to use informal tell us
about the politicians so I'm going to do
a little science introduction so that
we're all on the same page with what our
goal is this will be very much a
practical description of what a real
time pipeline is in in astrophysics so
one of the things that we're after in
astrophysics is the discovery and
follow-up of supernova and supernova is
an explosion of a star it's the death
state of a star they're the brightest
explosions in the universe the material
that a supernova ejects can travel up to
twenty percent the speed of light they
outshine a galaxy in which they're
formed which is comprised of billions or
trillions of stars for a period of a
month and in in one month time it will
admit as much energy as our Sun well
over its whole ten billion year lifetime
and a supernova explodes rises in days
to weeks and then falls down in a
comparable time and then decays away and
the interesting part about supernova is
catching them very very early because
this is where you learn the most physics
in a very short time especially related
to the system from which it was warned
how frequent are they somewhere in the
universe there is a supernova exploding
every single second in a galaxy like our
Milky Way there's one supernova per
century we find typically today in all
the Astrophysical surveys on the order
one two three new supernova most are
very distant they're about a billion
light years away so doing the math you
have to look at about a hundred thousand
galaxies like our Milky Way every night
to find one to two new supernovae and so
here is a picture of a supernovae 1010
years later
and this is a picture from the Chandra
x-ray telescope so the supernova has now
pushed out it was seen by ancient
observers all across so we've been
studying supernova for well over a
thousand years this one exploded on the
fourth of July and it was so bright in
our own Milky Way galaxies that it cast
shadows at night and there are
descriptions of people in Egypt reading
books outdoors by the light of the
supernova the Chinese have an excellent
term they call them guest stars because
like all good guests they come and then
they go okay and so I prefer that to
supernovae okay so why do we bother
studying it everything on the periodic
table beyond hydrogen and helium gets
out into the universe due to supernova
explosions okay and especially
everything down here the the gold in my
teeth the calcium in my bones all come
from supernova explosions cosmology in
2011 a Nobel Prize was awarded to Saul
Perlmutter who was my boss when this
project was going on that used supernova
as standard candles to measure the
acceleration of the universe and
discover what we now term as dark energy
and of course i'm at a do ii lab and i
would say a lot of the weapons physics
that has been done at places like
Livermore and Sandia and Los Alamos
really relies on our understanding of
the nuclear physics in supernova
explosions which we can observe so
there's many reasons for why we want to
study this now this is a picture of a
Hubble diagram this is a measurement of
the expansion of the universe which we
can get by the shifting of the light and
the relative brightness of the standard
candles of type 1a supernovae and this
was the measurements that that resulted
in the 2011 Nobel Prize and what it saw
was that the supernova that were distant
at a certain expansion were fainter than
what we were expecting and this implied
that
there was an antigravity force out there
dark energy that was causing the
universe to accelerate and expand its
expansion accelerate in contradiction to
gravity which would pull it together or
slow it down and so this was quite
shocking you need nearby supernova and
these are the supernova sort of less
than a billion light years away to you
know this is on the order of 60 million
light-years away and these are several
billion light years away you need the
nearby supernova to anchor this diagram
so that you can measure which one of
these tracks it's taking and it turns
out that it's much harder to find these
nearby ones than it is the distant once
and it's just a very simple geometric
effect put my arms out like this this is
my image I take a picture I get four or
five people in the back row one person
in the front row in my field of view so
I'm going to have to take four times as
many images to get the same number of
people in the front row ins in the back
in one image okay so so that's what's
going on here and of course it became a
cottage industry to try to find more and
more of these things but this part prove
daunting and that is what we're going to
talk about so in 1998 we were at the
four-metre Victor Blanco telescope in
the background here here are the two
teams that made chris smith and myself
outside it's cloudy night so we're not
goofing off okay and we were taking back
then they had 12 k by 2k ccd got
upgraded later on to be four of these
and you transfer this data back via what
amounted to a 56k baud modem from the
telescope and it would be subtracted all
of the stuff would be handled processed
within a few hours of dawn and we were
taking exposures that were on the order
of 5 to 10 minutes long and this is sort
of what the the pipeline looks and this
pipeline will be very similar regardless
of which ones I'm talking about you take
a bunch of reference images on the sky
maybe a month ago round new moon and
then you come back slightly
before new moon again and you take a
whole bunch more images and then you DIF
subtract them and you look for the new
points of light and then when you find
this then you schedule up spectroscopy
to determine its distance and its
redshift and that's usually done at the
Keck telescope and then maybe you want
to get infrared data so you have to go
above our atmosphere in your schedule
follow-up time at the Hubble Space
Telescope and we do this for about 50 to
200 pointings on the sky and you can see
the case is about you know in a month's
time we'll take a set of images come
back 34 weeks later take another set and
then we'll find 20 ish supernova and
we'll schedule those for follow-up
spectroscopy the turnaround wasn't that
great I actually could fly back with the
tapes and sometimes I would beat the
data back if the networking wasn't so
great and we'd process the data at
Berkeley and we'd often rely on the fact
that too low low was about six hours
behind Hawaii in order to give us a
little buffer so that we could get
spectra that following night this is
sort of what the image subtractions look
like so there's a reference image a new
image and a difference and here is a
super nova sitting on a galaxy
impossible to see if you're just looking
at the image but also note there are
some spurious detections here here are
some bright stars that are near the
saturation limit or there's a
astrometric misalignment the images
weren't registered properly and per
image for one of these two K by 2 k.c
CDs you get about 200 5 Sigma detections
the majority of these are bogus and what
we'll talk about that in a little bit we
made cuts based on things like shape
motion we always require two images to
confirm it sometimes you'll get an
asteroid that will pass nicely in front
of a galaxy you think you have a
supernova and then 10 minutes later when
you take another image its moved so we'd
always take two but you'd wind up making
these cuts and you'd have about five
things that a humid wouldn't have to
interact
can look at per image so maybe somewhere
around a thousand per night and there
were ten of us or so on the project and
we'd take a look at this and get them
all and everybody would look at the same
object multiple times and and that
things were fine and you're doing this
just once a month maybe two three months
out of the year not that big of a deal
we had in our first attempts to do some
nearby work at telescopes in Arizona an
issue which was the networking was
non-existent and so somebody suggested
don't underestimate the bandwidth of a
station wagon filled with dat tapes and
it's very true we actually shipped raid
array hard drives down in a FedEx
caravan of basically three of these
things and they'd go down they'd load up
the data send it back and another one
would be down on its way and we
maintained 200 kilobytes per second we
started looking at two orders of
magnitude more data to build up our
nearby sample and we were still using
the same software so we had people
looking at two orders of magnitude more
data so the first thing that went away
was redundancy we no longer had multiple
people looking at the same object we had
one person scanning a certain set and
another person and of course scanners
have different qualities and you hire
new people and they don't know what's
going on and things degraded a little
bit and real time for us turned into
something about 48 hours but that was
all right we were interested in
measuring the peaks of these supernovae
to make them our standard candles the
peak brightness so if it was a few days
later not that big of a deal okay but
then we got involved with something
called the Palomar transient factory
this is a the Schmidt telescope a
48-inch telescope down here at Mount
Palomar it's off between LA and San
Diego up in the mountains and the nice
part about this was was that fifty
percent of the 60 inch telescope was
devoted for follow-up
and we could control that telescope
during the middle of the night so if we
found something interesting we could say
hey this guy continue on with your
plowing of the sky and this one go ahead
and take off some other follow-up data
either spectroscopy or photometry
whatever you want and and we own fifty
percent of the night and we could do
that the best part was that our
networking issues was solved we got
involved with the HP Wren network there
were microwave relay stations going down
to San Diego supercomputing center and
then up on ES net through here so that
solved a lot of our networking issues
and our problems there but we're going
to encounter some problems in the future
that's a 555 megabits per second
connection this was sort of our view of
the world at the time if we look at the
decay time so the rise and fall fifty
percent of the light versus the peak
brightness and here is where our
supernova this is on a log scale we had
discovered things in this area so scales
of you know 10 15 20 days up to a
hundred days and things that are fainter
classical nova which aren't the death of
a star but just a little burp before
final death we had discovered these
areas but there were all these predicted
areas by theorists as to where other
things could go on time scales that were
much smaller just rise and fall within a
couple days or even hours okay two
things that were much longer but much
fainter and we wanted to start to
explore this and and so this is the
telescope that we used it's a 92
megapixel telescope it has one arcsecond
resolution so that's the width of a dime
at one mile that's one each of these
pixels here and we could get down to 20
first magnitude in 60 seconds so that's
a million times fainter than the human
eye could see so we're going from five
to ten minute exposures with one chip to
60 second exposures on a dozen ships and
we would take 300 of these per night and
these were all the science projects so
it wasn't just us go
laughter supernova we had lots and lots
of people interested in all these
different types of Astrophysical events
and so we had to we had a whole new set
of customers that were interested in
different things and these are on
different time scales and they require
different follow-up mechanisms and so it
complicated things but it also brought a
lot of resources because these not only
did we have fifty percent of the palomar
60-inch but members of this
collaboration had access to follow up on
all these other telescopes going from
the Hubble telescope to the twink x 10
meter telescopes to small one meter
telescopes in the desert in Israel so
all of these could be brought to bear if
you knew what type of thing you were on
and if you got on it early enough to
make their science profitable so we
created a pipeline at nurse and so the
data is coming in at about 250 megabytes
every minute you get about 100 gigabytes
during a typical night course shorter in
the summer longer in the winter it comes
through on our data transfer nodes and
it gets dumped on the nurse global file
system we have a science gateway that
basically has a database that's
maintaining the pipeline what images are
coming in do they have a reference image
can we make a subtraction if so shove it
over to now it's on Cory run a
subtraction place the subtractions back
on the global file system then another
science gateway so that our
collaborators could view all of this on
the web okay breaking it down here's the
transfers so this is the networking part
of this coming all the way from the
telescope over the microwave relay to es
net and then coming in where we do the
image processing taking out the
electronic noise registering it to the
reference image doing an image
subtraction stacking up multiple images
of the same field during the night and
then querying it against various
catalogs like a known star catalogues
okay well somebody wants to know is this
a supernova it better be going off in a
galaxy if this is something closer to us
in the Milky Way galaxy it should be
associated with a star so we check that
we do this screening as to whether or
not the object is real or not and then
I'll show you that in just a bit and
this involves a lot of heavy database
access and then of course publishing
this up even to the point of eventually
sending out a trigger on a cell phone or
moving a telescope okay the database we
have a post grads database in in PTF
which went from 2009 to 2012 we process
two million images 40,000 reference
images over one and a half million
subtractions over a billion candidates
that were detected and out of those
50,000 that we we saved of course they
have multiple epochs and this was 815
One Nights of imaging so in a typical
night on 300 x 12 chips you generate
about 1.5 million candidates most of
them are not real they're due to image
artifacts misalignment or saturation
issues from bright stars you get about
50,000 asteroids which aren't
interesting to me but interesting to
other people a thousand or two thousand
variable stars that are changing their
brightness 100 supernova but most of
these are old we've discovered already
and maybe three to four new young
supernova or other types of explosions
and so it truly is a needle in a
haystack and this is sort of what it
looks like so here's the one good one
that I showed you but take a look over
here these are all the artifacts these
are all completely garbage and so you
have to get rid of all of those so how
did we do this well we did it the hard
way we did it the old-fashioned way for
three months the first three months of
PTF we used the hand scanning routine
and there were about 20 of us or so that
went through and looked at all this data
and then we set up basically how well do
people scan so this is basically a
histogram of how alike are you to other
people okay so if you're in the middle
here that means your result whether it
was good or bad was very similar to
everybody else's if you're on this side
you were more conservative and said more
things were real if you're on this side
you said more things were false then the
average person so it determines your
scanners bias so this was a problem that
we had before what if you have somebody
look at it and they're just not as good
I'm actually right here because I
probably scanned more data than anybody
else so most I agreed or everybody else
agreed with me more often than not this
is a friend of mine who worked just a
few years less than me he's pretty good
but then you can see people I know who
this issues now a professor at Caltech
she wanted everything to be real okay
and and this was a young graduate
student who thought everything was
absolute garbage and so he was on the
other side but this was great because
then we could have them look at data
that then other people didn't see and we
knew what their biases were and we could
adjust for that and so we created a
random force that was trained to
generate what we call real bogus scores
and of course the majority of the things
are bogus but here are two examples of
reals okay ref new sub okay and you can
see the subtraction here and this is
lower to signal to noise so you get
something that has a real bogus score of
about point two and this is really high
you get about point seven so one is
perfect and zero is garbage and we use
to cut off somewhere around point one a
little bit lower than that and then the
great part was once we got to detection
that were about point one or higher in
the same location then we knew we had a
good object to go after and then Josh
bloom built a robot which basically
queried our database said how many
objects now have two confirmed good
detection and then once that was done go
out in query all the world's databases
on this location in the sky and let's
try to provide added value and publish
this to the collaboration so it's the
first step in classification has
somebody else looked at this galaxy do
they know how far away it is does it
have a history of supernova going off in
it or is this a variable star that
somebody else is studying
so this is very useful to then help you
direct your follow-up we didn't stop
there we decided to do a citizen science
project called Galaxy Zoo supernova and
and what we did was after we fired up
that and we started classifying things
we sent out we lowered our cuts not 2.1
but we lowered it down to point 05 and
we just flooded them and said have a
look at it and the real trick was coming
up how do you how do you get a citizen
scientist who knows nothing about this
to look at a set of ref new and sub and
judge that that's a good object and so a
lot of time was spent in and to do it
quickly developing for questions
decision tree yes no questions to
whether or not these were good she was
very very successful it opened up a lot
more space to us it taught us how well
we were doing they could look at so many
more objects in 2010 we did this study
where they plowed through 25,000 objects
there were 1,200 people that were signed
up at the time in in basically three
hours and so and at the top 50 things
that they discovered were all summer the
rest were junk there was no way we could
we could have done that we published
this work in a paper called Galaxy Zoo
supernova it was a very nicely
thought-out project by the folks at
Oxford onto how to do this and how to
use these resources we learned some
great things about using crowdsourcing
in England at the time so back then they
had pub laws which basically shut down
the pub at midnight ok and so common
practice in England is when they rang
the bell for last call people would
order a couple pints and throw them both
down before they left and they went out
on the street and maybe if they had no
other plans for the night they would
come home and start searching for
supernova and their quality was greatly
diminished compared to those that were
taking say a coffee break or a tea break
i guess if you're in england at ten or
eleven in the morning and we noticed
this quality control
so it was we could correct for this bias
as well so so that was interesting Josh
took all of this data and with Heinrich
here in his time domain group went
through and increased the data set
tremendously and came up with what we
call real bogus too which is still in
use today a new random forest train
where they did a lot more work and and
you could see this is the machine
learning zoo versus the human zoo we
were able to improve our ROC so here's
the Miss detection rate versus the false
positive rate this is opposite of the
way a lot of people show it but you want
to drive here have the fewest false
positives and the fewest mists and they
could easily outperform the humans so we
shut off the Galaxy Zoo project at that
time once we determine we used all the
data that they generated and once we
determined we could do it better through
machines and then this is what we then
used to do our real bogus separation
okay so then the project got to a point
where we really wanted to focus on the
pipeline so this is where we are today
one when we started we had 24 hour
turnaround about a year later I was
sitting down I had a Keck night I said I
want to take a spectrum of something
that just blew up so by hand i ran the
pipeline and i ran the machine learning
on it and we took spectra of things and
I said this is great I want to automate
this now and so due to a project called
ex swap extreme scale scientific
workflow analysis and prediction we were
able to instrument our entire pipeline
and I'll talk a little bit about this
and so this is what we mean by real-time
now so this is a histogram of the number
of seconds from the time we close the
shutter to the time we have candidates
in the database and we've classified
them and they've been published and so
it's a logarithmic scale here so
basically in under 10 minutes the
majority of our data is now totally
processed and out there and ready to
trigger the palomar 60 inch telescope so
can Slough over and start taking images
with a very very small error rate we
actually raised our constraints a lot
and we have yet to trigger it on
something which is false this is mostly
the work of Yi Kao at Cal Tech and this
was the thing that we were able to do we
put checkpoints in with at every single
processing step and this shows you two
different nights and the time it takes
at these various checkpoints so that we
could look exactly at what's taking a
very long time on one night and then
concentrate on our efforts on improving
those algorithms and improving that code
so we could minimize or at least
understand the interaction so right now
for about eight hours every night we
know more about the nurse center than
they do in real time because we're
monitoring everything from database
access to processing to their global
file system to their burst buffers tu es
net pumping in data so here's an example
of the time in seconds it takes to get
an image from the telescope to the nurse
center and you can see it as a function
of the night so it starts out slow it
picks up in speed and then towards the
morning it kicks up again reason being
people are still awake and using the
network this network HP Ren is used by a
lot of the Native American reservations
that are out on that side and so when
these people finally go off to bed then
the network moves very very quickly so
we have this type of lag which is
inherent and it's not huge it's it's
only about 20 seconds from worst to best
this is the plot of the time it takes to
process an observation / the median time
it takes looking at that part of the sky
okay and then the number of candidates
on the object when we go and observe if
the moon's out the sky is brighter we
don't see as far away there's a lot more
noise okay so we have less objects to
look at okay so that influenced us even
for the same piece of sky we can change
how
we're going the atmosphere can be more
disturbed so things get blurred out that
lowers our sensitivity as well or it can
get really sharp and increase our
sensitivity so what you see here is that
there's a very nice decent trend for
just generically the number of objects
that you have okay that will lead to
more false positive objects that you
have to process and then query okay but
then there's some scatter here and this
scatter is most likely a result of a job
coming through and taking slightly
longer than you expected in interfering
with another dub so than previous talk I
really like the idea of running
something that was controlled in the
sense that I wouldn't start processing
another job until I was done with my
first job because I know the overall
performance would be better whereas in
some of these cases I'm probably having
lots of jobs hit the same date part of
the sky or the database at the same time
you could imagine giving up your
database now where you have different
parts of the sky spread out into
different databases so you're not
querying the same database at the same
time and then set up your imaging so
you're not hitting the same part of this
guy but slew across the sky one after
the other to start to mitigate these
issues and that's the things that we're
looking at now so we're now exploring
the relationship between nightly
conditions and the bulk of the data
through machine learning so we're
actually using the information that we
get from the telescope to then make a
prediction of how long it's going to
take and this right here is sort of what
we expect you know the majority of the
stuff is going to oscillate twenty
thirty percent but we get some outliers
and these outliers are most likely
problems with the compute center at
nurse something has gone wrong some
glitch and we're trying to understand
these and we're trying to actually come
up with ways to send automated messages
to the nurse staff to inform them hey
our pipeline is running four times
slower than we expected it there's some
problem with your system please go fix
it to date we have spectroscopically
confirmed over 2,700 supernova a hundred
thousand galactic transients and ten
thousand transient
m31 that's our nearest neighbor it's
produced 138 publications six in nature
and two in science since 2009 and these
are the ones that I'm going to talk
about because these were enabled by this
real-time this is an image of the
northern hemisphere we don't tend to
look in the Milky Way galaxy and we
can't see of course down into the
southern hemisphere so this part of the
sky is blocked off but you can see in
parts of the sky we've taken over 7,000
images on any spot so we have a long
temporal history we also use that
knowledge to inform us about new objects
so here's one of them in 2011 we
discovered the brightest type 1a
supernovae in the last 25 years the 5th
brightest supernova in the last century
of any type here it was on august
twenty-third then 24th and 25th here you
can see it near peak brightness right
there in this beautiful pinwheel galaxy
we caught at 11 hours after explosion
and we were able to get spectroscopy of
it basically six hours after that on the
Canary Islands once the sunset there we
were able to trigger spectroscopy
because it was caught so early we were
able to measure the size of the star
that exploded and constrain it by these
first observations and this proved that
this was the explosion of a
carbon-oxygen white dwarf star which is
something that we had always assumed but
we never had direct proof of before
we've done something called flash
spectroscopy so here are a bunch of non
detection and here are two detection on
the same night okay screaming up here's
the in hours and we were able to turn
around and just a little bit later just
a couple hours later get a spectrum at
the Keck telescope and then you can see
that we triggered all of this follow-up
so this is the first 12 hours since
explosion the first image come in loaded
in the database automated transient
alert after the second image came in and
this got text spectrum just taken a few
hours later and then all these other
telescopes within the ground in space
what was incredible
this supernova was that when a supernova
explodes a shock wave comes off of the
surface of the star and it's incredibly
bright and it's like a light bulb all of
a sudden you turn on a gazillion watt
light bulb and this one went off it's a
wolf or a star and there's a cloud of
gas around it it's rather extended and
it lit up this cloud of gas a million
times brighter than it normally is so
this is not something that we can
observe in another galaxy that's 60
million light-years away these that you
know we can barely pull out if there's
star there let alone the cloud of gas or
anything we can't take a spectrum of it
that's barely detected with the Hubble
Space Telescope at a couple Sigma but
what we saw here was a spectrum that
looked like other wolf ray stars in our
own galaxy which we they are bright
enough in near enough that we can do and
we could actually classify it down to
what was the abundance of nitrogen to
helium we could perfectly predict what
this star was before it blew up because
it lit up this now the thing is the
supernova is expanding at ten percent
the speed of light and it quickly
overtakes this cloud of gas and then
starts to look like a normal supernova
so we only had that few our window of
opportunity to see this gas cloud lit up
by the shock of the supernova so that's
one of the things that this real-time
turnaround enables yes what are we
actually seeing in these images is that
a photographic image yeah this this
right here is a wolf rayet star in our
Milky Way galaxy okay just just use and
this is a photometry of the area and it
is probably done in three different
filters to give us some color and this
is hydrogen gas around it taking with a
very specific h-alpha filter right
around the hydrogen line how close does
such a thing
have to be for us to be worried oh very
close there are not any good stars that
we have to worry about we will there's
do you know the constellation Orion have
you seen that and so one of the
shoulders is Betelgeuse that's a red
star that will go supernova and it'll be
pleasant enough that you'll be able to
see it during the daytime ok for a
couple months but that's about it it's
not going to cause if one of the nearest
stars blew up to us that would be a very
big problem here's another one that we
discover sedan cason who's a professor
here made a prediction back in 2010 that
if a supernova blows up and it has a
companion star it'll run into that
companion star and the material from the
supernova will get shocked heated and if
you're looking down this line of sight
you should be able to see that and we
actually did in just last year on 2015
we had the first evidence for this sort
of shock heating for supernova running
into its companion star not something
you expect to see all the time because
if you're looking this way you won't see
the shot region but once again something
that you need to catch within the first
few hours because the supernova will
overrun it and then you won't see
anything let's see here ok gravitational
waves you guys have heard about thee yes
ah so we're trying to look at these
stars so once it gets hit then its
atmosphere gets shocked heated and so
depending on what type of star it is it
could puff up due to all the extra
energy that was injected into there and
so we hope to go and look for these
types of sars and it will slowly cool
down over decades so it gives us a
chance to search for the star it'll also
get dumped with all the metals that I
talked about to come out in a supernova
explosion the calcium the iron etc
that'll get dumped in there and be very
unusual so there's chance that we can
actually take spectra of these things
and see that they were victims of a
supernova explosion so gravity would
it's have been recently detected this is
an incredible new area and this is where
I think time-domain astrophysics is
going to be headed dominated in the next
decade is the follow-up of these
gravitational wave triggers so we had to
30 solar mass black holes and now the
more recent ones are slightly smaller
mess the problem is you have two
detectors okay so they use the time
difference between the two detectors to
give you its location but if you think
about it since you don't have three you
can't triangulate so all you do is get a
plane in the sky where it could come
from and this was the plane and this was
sort of the 1 Sigma 2 Sigma and these
were the three sigma error bars for
where this plane was it was mostly in
the southern hemisphere so we couldn't
do a tremendous amount of follow-up but
we targeted this area here for follow-up
right after the trigger now you can see
also that this is well if you if you can
translate this in this guy there's a
large chunk of the sky okay they just
didn't know where this went off okay
it's like yes somewhere there so 15
different follow-up surveys went and
plowed this part of the sky four of them
run at nurse their pipelines that I
built this is where the Palomar
transient factory went and it got
spectra so ref new sub and this is a
pre-existing image from the sloan
digital sky survey of the area and we
got specter of all these objects okay
these were all new objects that went off
that we did not know about okay none of
them were associated with this
gravitational wave trigger two black
holes we actually don't expect any light
from these things so the first thing was
you're still getting about a million
things you have to sift through them and
then in addition you get some real
things and then you have to trigger on
them okay so we would like to use
historical information did we take an
image there last night was there
something there that was just below our
detection threshold coming up that we
now see etc this is going to be the big
big thing not only to react to the
gravitational wave trigger paved the sky
with imaging but then determine which
ones are good and which ones are
interesting
further spectroscopic follow-up and and
donate your big telescope time to going
after those this is our diagram now of
characteristic time scale versus peak
luminosity the gray areas of the areas
we sort of knew about before and these
are all the interesting objects that
we've now populated this notice that
it's still sort of barren over here we
actually think some of the gravitational
wave triggers will be in here from
neutron star black hole or neutron star
Neutron storm mergers and that's what
we're hoping to see the optical
signatures for ok so I'll finish up here
with just a couple slides on future
problems in this area so here is the
horrible thing these are upper limits ok
and then here are detections and here is
the underlying light curve of this
object time versus brightness and so we
don't detect it here and you can see our
limits go up and down because the moon
comes up and we get worse and then goes
away and we get better and then maybe
seeing improves the atmospheric
disturbance goes down and all of a
sudden we make to detection ok so we hit
this part of the sky and we go in and we
say ah to detection something's rising
let's trigger on that ok we don't really
want to do this and what we want to do
is see this and then immediately go back
and start adding this data together to
get an improved detection threshold to
see if something that was below our 5
Sigma detection threshold earlier was
actually there and then we wouldn't
follow this oh we say oh it was fainter
it was back here ignore it this is the
type of thing that we'd like to do
because of this we are now implementing
triggers on objects which we find oops
and the triggering ok of new
subtractions where we're stacking data
in real time is actually comparable to
the use of our whole pipeline during the
night so this is a sort of a feedback
that's coming into our pipeline
depending upon where we're looking
depending on how often we're looking
and it's it's really complicating
matters and introducing very interesting
problems for us in terms of data flow
and and our use of the databases and
this is a final slide here of where
we're headed so thus wiki transient
facility is going to start up next year
this is the detector it's 16 6k by 6k
chips and this is the previous one the
12 2k by 4k chips so it's a factor of
five more an area we're going to switch
from 60-second exposures two 30-second
exposures and we're going to read out
the chips faster three times faster so
just in terms of our relative aerial
survey rate will be 15 times faster but
because we're taking exposures which are
half as long our volumetric won't be
quite that but it will be a factor of 12
so will produce an order of magnitude
more candidates this is great for the
gravitational wave follow up because the
uncertainties are about three pointings
of one of these once they get the third
detector online and they can move from
that swath to a chunk of sky that's
roughly 100 square degrees so we'll be
able to pave over 100 square degrees in
just three of these pointings the
problem is is that we now have an order
of magnitude more data and we're going
to find a lot more objects and we're
going to want to go back and in real
time ask the question if we stack the
data here if we look at it in a
different way are there things that we
can use to tell us this is really an
interesting object to go after or not
and so that's where our challenge is to
get rid of those things that look like
potentially interesting and just hone in
on the really really exciting stuff
because with an order of magnitude more
data we're going to have more of those
every single night and so I'll leave it
there and take any questions thanks
so how much of the decision-making about
following up which telescopes to bring
you to the action and so on how much is
human and how much is automated so uh
the first so there so if we get a
gravitational wave trigger it actually
takes over the palomar 40 inch 8-inch
survey and so it will design a scanning
pattern that will go in there and then
all of the objects found in there above
a certain threshold no human interaction
it will trigger the palomar 60 inch to
follow up those objects immediately and
provide more data about two to three
objects per night on that level are
triggered automatically with the palomar
60-inch about one object per week sends
out an SOS on collection of cell phones
fortunately my name is no longer on that
list to wake people up or two since we
have a bunch of European collaborators
notify them that there's something
interesting they'll take a look at it
and decide on the appropriate follow-up
resources we have yet to convince other
telescopes of how good we are in this to
let us interrupt them via a computer
they still require a human to call them
up so only the telescope's we own do we
actually have computer go after and
we're very confident of that but you
know there's the adage the lone
astronomer at the telescope doesn't want
to receive a message that says you must
now slew over here stop your
observations and take a spectrum of this
for these people and by the way nobody
sent this to you except a computer at
this IP address there they're not quite
ready for that yet so hopefully in
another few years they will be
all these other people who are sort of
manually doing are they moving more
towards your methodology or uh so they
want to and I would say the problem is
is that the cost of the experiment is
and that's just telescope and you know
operations cost is comparable to the
computing costs and the staff required
to keep this type of system up and
running and scientists always are cheap
on the computing systems compared to
their experiment and so they would like
to but they don't quite have that
capability so I believe more of them
will you use it use something like this
when high-performance computing centers
become more amenable for somebody to
dump their workflow on there and have it
automated and run and they don't have to
pay for it so yeah
making
maybe coming from us so well so it was
interesting the first talk this morning
so I think the biggest thing for us is
is knowing what so types of things like
what's the best way to take a historical
data set so if you're looking at the
streaming data what's the best way to
take the historical bit of that to
constantly improve your predictions
about the new data sets coming down so
that's that's one thing I think a much
better understanding of when we trigger
a certain query how much is that going
to cause the delay of the pipeline in
our system what type of resources do we
need to bring to bear in order to lessen
that type of impact so it's it's one of
those things you want to take the hit
off the fire hose of the real-time data
and you want to process that but
simultaneously you want to ask deeper
questions where you know the first brush
question might get you to swing a
telescope might not but if we looked a
little bit more we definitely would have
swung the telescope over and so how do
you layer those so that they don't
interact with each other in a
detrimental way so that you can still
keep up with this flow of data you know
and it's it's a tricky thing it's it you
know it's these databases we've got to
figure out how to replicate and query
them in ways in real time so that they
don't interfere with each other but
they're kept completely up to date we've
got to figure about doing processing
maybe at other places where we can ask
deeper questions of the data than we
currently are those are the types of
things that we're having real problems
with and this gets worse with LSST is
wiki transient factory so large synoptic
survey telescope which comes online in
five ish years is going to be two orders
of magnitude larger than z TF + z TF is
already interesting because the 30
seconds here this saturates are
work and it saturates our network at the
best time during the night so earlier in
the night late early in the morning we
won't be able this this will be degraded
we won't have this type of turn around
so we can also ask the question well
what if we took longer exposures then
and then our network issues goes away do
we tune it based upon what we know our
network performance is how does that
influence our pipeline in our turn
around so it's the modeling I would say
it's sort of the semi analytic modeling
of the the whole pipeline that's that's
an area that we need to know where
there's feedback and it's complicated it
seems like from not really point of view
understanding there's a key step which
was this ml zoo place again that's where
the decision make this is that's that's
where the first level of decision is
this a good transient even think about
something about the methods involve the
early that's it spread yes so so it's a
feature-based extraction on the
reference new and sub we cut out stamps
of 100 by 100 pixels around each object
it's a random forest trained on features
on each of the image so sort of signal
to noise shape location with respect to
whatever objects in the ref there about
20 or 30 of these and josh and his group
did a job in going through and looking
at these characteristics pruning the
trees if you will to figure out which
ones were the most important features
and then doing that we have also gone
through on a purely pixel-based one
we've trained these on neuromorphic
chips the IBM true north we've been able
to achieve this sort of level of
performance that's you know sort of a
one-percent well sub one percent false
positive when we require two images we
required one image and we had some
knowledge of whether or not it was an
asteroid we could probably do better but
we're not ready to quite go there yet
just a follow-up Nancy you you're
looking for
specific class of object right meanwhile
you know are there you know are you sort
of also looking for stray strange things
yeah so one of the very interesting
things that we discovered was the
classification robot that Josh built was
not quite infallible and so there is a
saying which is you'll find what you're
searching for and and this is very very
true in our field and the robot would go
through and it had certain bins that it
would stick things into and classifying
majority of the time it did it right but
when it encountered something which just
was outside of anything it would miss
classify it and humans then would not
look at it because oh it said oh it's a
variable star okay well whatever we
don't need to react to that immediately
and it turned out to be a completely new
type of transient phenomena and we
missed it now we happen to catch it
later on when the robot was offline and
humans had to look at things and do
classification so now we've tried to get
away from that and we've tried to be
very very conscious of that statement
that you you will find what you're
searching for and we've tried to remove
that from from the whole thing so that
is that's a challenge for us as well and
and you use is always some sort of
opportunity for prospecting for strange
yeah so that's so one of the things that
we have now of course we have this
year's worth of data and so we can go
back through it and look at it in new
ways and with a completely open mind or
a completely radical thought go in and
search for something that nobody ever
expected so and we're trying to do that
one of the things that we look for is
orphan afterglows from gamma ray bursts
so gamma ray burst is a trigger of
gamma-ray light and then it creates an
optical shock which lasts just for a few
hours there have been satellites
developed to find these things and then
slow and get optical data on them but we
have actually found the counterparts
where there was no gamma-ray signal at
all and we've seen this and that's not
something that we're set up to find
because by their very nature they decay
instead of getting brighter
and so it was not something we were
looking for we relaxed our search
requirements we've now found six of
these things and it's incredible
completely new science field because the
requirement of having a gamma ray burst
means that the gamma rays were being
towards you and it's a very collimated
beam and now they're going off like this
but we're still seeing the optical which
is more global and so it's giving us
completely new physics understanding of
these objects so so there hopefully
there are a lot more things like that
and with ztf we're going to change our
cadence we're going to have a much
higher cadence so there are a lot more
opportunity to mine this data for new
things so so right now they're all
internal but when ztf starts its funded
by the National Science Foundation and
they mandated we publish everything in
real time so we're going to publish it
and we're going to publish it with a
quality control estimate on our half how
likely we think this is a real event and
there's a a thing called vo event a
virtual observatory event which has a
whole mechanism for doing this and
distributing it and alerting people and
matter of fact there are protocols set
up for telescopes if they so desire to
take that feed and do stuff with it so
yes that's where we're headed so that'll
be april of next year is one that will
start yeah so maybe i don't understand
it but everything just seems like you're
focused on is camera taking images do
you have any kind of video streaming or
any aspect like that no so so the follow
up though can be of all sorts so this is
cameras taking imaging but we can be
triggered by other sources which are
which are different and we can trigger
follow-up radio telescopes which take
data in very different ways high-speed
cameras which are taking images at
fractions of a second things like that
we trigger but this is just you know 30
seconds get
an image process it look for something
new
big nose